foreign
Kelsey's up next in Baton Rouge Kelsey
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you absolutely I wanted to get
your advice my husband and I are trying
to make a difficult decision we're on
our debt-free journey and we've got two
daughters that are young but
exceptionally talented at gymnastics and
we're trying to decide if we should sell
our home to become debt free and to be
able to continue to support their
gymnastics or should we stay in our home
and maybe pull them out so that we can
really kick start our baby step Journey
wow why is selling the house your first
option
we have a lot of equity in our home
um
our modest home
that's a reason to sell it not so that
we can
be able to ship our kids all over the
country
yeah if I I I'm really hesitant for you
to use your kids as an excuse to make
any sort of decision you all need to
make what's the best decision for your
family and your living needs and your
financial situation and then the kids
come on the back end of that
sure they can't carry the weight of
their parents hopes and dreams we sold
the house for you to do gymnastics and
now you don't want to do gymnastics
anymore now you just want to smoke
cigarettes yeah and they can't carry
that weight you know what I mean they
can't we wouldn't want to do that I will
say we originally had planned on selling
our home so we could quickly become debt
free and and have that peace since my
husband's our Sole Provider we're ready
to get there but then we recently had
the thought that we could just take them
out of gymnastics and make it work to
stay in this house which is where I
guess how much is gymnastics costing you
um gymnastics for both of them total is
870 a month
and that doesn't include travel does it
um it doesn't but the majority of our
meets are local and I'm pretty sure we
have the option to decline any travel at
this stage since they're so young so
what would
something in your gut says put taking
them out on the table what is it
um it is a lot of money and if we took
them out I guess crunching the numbers
either way we end up hopefully with a
paid for house at 40 years old
completely debt free but one option is
they're still in gymnastics but we're in
a more modest home whereas the other
option is staying in this home taking
them out and and then we have a much
nicer home that's paid for
I would look at cutting all other
expenses increasing income taking on
side jobs and staying in the home and
selling the home to me is a last-ditch
option unless you guys just hate this
house and want to move anyways but
that's a huge step to take just to keep
affording gymnastics yeah again I would
not do this because of gymnastics if
gymnastics if you're able to afford it
because you've done this fine I always
want parents to ask themselves are we
keeping our kids in after school sports
and Elite travel stuff to fulfill our
dreams
or for our kids most kids just want time
with their parents